mika safranov est un célèbre peintre
russe décoré par le il a immortalisé et
rencontrer les plus puissantes ce monde
y compris tous les présidents américains
depuis bill clinton jusqu'à dans l'autre
l'original de cette toile a même été
offerte au président pour le féliciter
de sa victoire en 2016 mpi venait ni
groupe
c'est un homme impulsif intelligent et
charismatique dix peintres les matchs
non mais sapronov dit qu'il était aussi
convaincus ou plus profond de son âme
que tu as un palais changer le regard
des américains sur la réussite rames par
mois se graisser au chiffre de choc
quatre ans plus tard il constate que
rien n'a changé parce qu'il a selon lui
les mains liées par le comble les moyens
d'aller chercher mines d'alès doc news
l'immédiat ressemble eux aussi avoir des
chances c'est du moins le discours de
l'animateur dimitri qui si l'homme qui
se veut l'un des plus importants
porte-voix du kram
il a reçu notre équipe sur son plateau
où tous les dimanches il analyse
l'actualité y compris celle des états
unis pour des millions de
téléspectateurs
reste que dans les faits les allégations
de collusion avec vladimir poutine
or ont hanté sinon définit une bonne
partie la présidence de nos routes
il ya quelques jours des élections les
services de renseignements américains
affirme une fois de plus et avoir des
preuves que le crème les manigances en
sa faveur et américaine ce qui est grave
c'est une joute interne est propre aux
états unis dit qu'ils sillonnent en
ajoutant que les américains sous donald
trump auront déposé plus de sanctions la
russie que sous n'importe quel autre
président
mais cette notion selon laquelle trump
est la marionnette le caniche de poutine
est exploité à fond en russie encore
aujourd'hui dans cette parole diffusé
par la chaîne du kremlin rachat d un
poste d'animateur
[Musique]
disons que l'engouement qui existaient
pour trois ans en russie il y a quatre
ans mais sur le campus de l'institut
d'état des relations internationales à
moscou les jeunes à qui nous avons parlé
sont tout de même fasciné par les
élections aux états unis c'est ici qu'on
forme les futurs diplomates de la
fédération russe
des jeunes comme aller et kirill qui
rêvent d'un poste en amérique tracts
dans une entrevue à la télévision le
président poutine a lui aussi dénoncé
cette rhétorique antirusse du candidat
démocrate
mais comme s'ils s'étaient résignés
il s'est aussi dit encouragé par le
désir de joe biden de négocier un
nouveau traité sur le contrôle des armes
nucléaires
car éviter une collision militaire entre
deux pays qui se disputent l'hégémonie
demeure le principal enjeu
dimitri cheney
[Musique]
mais en attendant résultats du 3
novembre
vu d'ici mais états unis sont divisés en
2020 et que le kremlin n'a pas vraiment
besoin de faire quoi que ce soit pour
créer la zizanie
si tel est le but mais pas aux cheminots
si la campagne électorale a été
bénéfique pour le kremlin
c'est qu'elle lui permet encore de dire
aux russes qu'ils n'ont rien mais
absolument rien à envier au mode de vie
des américains